james is trying to call his friend paul
he can remember and then he gives you a
whole series of facts
then asks this what's the maximum number
of calls
jason needs to make to reach his friend
assuming all calls are answered so i
guess the idea is this
because he's going to be trying a whole
bunch of numbers and he's not sure which
one it's going to be right the maximum
number of calls is
well how many different possibilities
are there for different numbers i'll
give you an example let me change this
okay suppose um
you're trying to ring up pizza hut
now this is um at least when when i was
younger watching tv this is the number
for pizza hut okay and there was like a
jingle that went along with it and
anyway
it's fairly easy to remember but suppose
i forgot okay so suppose
there we go i didn't know what that last
number was okay so what am i gonna do
i'm gonna get out my phone
okay well suppose i can't remember the
jingle and i'm just gonna try well for
instance for instance i might dial and i
might try this number nine four eight
one
double one one
three right right i give it a call and
someone else is like yeah hello this is
ali i'm like do you make pizzas you're
there like no i don't mean pizzas sorry
i think you got the wrong number so i'll
hang up right and i'm like well this
one's wrong this one's wrong okay so
then i'll try another one i'll just you
know i'll read this one
okay so i'll be like hello it'll be like
yeah this is luke i'm like luke do you
make pizzas and he's like no go away i
mean i do make pizzas but i'm not going
to make a pizza for you so wrong number
okay hang up so you get the idea i'm
going to go through this and now how
many different times am i going to have
to call
they're going to be 10 different ones
because there will be three there'll be
four
obviously there'll be one and two
five six seven eight nine and then there
will be zero
ah now just wait i'm trying to
illustrate
the way it works because i could just
give you the answer but i want you to
see how i got there
so
the first idea is okay
i'm going to have to trial an error
through these numbers now in this
situation
there are 10 options so the maximum
number of times i would call would be 10
times eventually
one of them i'll hit the actual number
now this is just a simple example let's
have a look at this example and try and
fit it into this okay
again it's an eight-digit number okay
and he knows the first six digits so
let's just give an example suppose the
first six digits were
well they all they'll actually they
don't even all start with nines anymore
let's start with eights and that kind of
thing so suppose these are the numbers
okay so it's an 8-digit phone number
right you can see there are going to be
eight numbers okay
and i know the first six digits
i know that no two digits are the same
right so you see none of them are the
same and these last two also not gonna
be the same
and there are no zeros okay now let's
have a think about this
so that means
i only have a few different choices for
what numbers can be here right they
can't be any of these numbers what are
the options that i've got one two three
four it can be a three or a two or one
no zeros right okay
so what i want to think about is well
how many different combinations are
there how many different
phone numbers can fit
this this pattern and these are only the
numbers i can do
well let's think about this you can
actually there are not that many you can
actually where's my likelihood
you can actually write them out
so for instance
i could do one two that would be okay
i could do two one there'll also be a
way okay
i could do uh one three or three one
there's one more pair that i can do
i could do two three
two and three two there are no more
possibilities because i'd have to use a
zero or i'd have to like i'd have to
repeat a number that's it
okay
why not why not four five six seven
okay now uh so good question
i can't use any of these numbers because
the question says there are no
two digits the same which is why i can't
even put two too okay carl question um
can you find out how many combinations
not without understanding more about how
this thing works
okay
now i can sort of go i can i can sort of
i can think about it i can explain it
another way okay so number one you could
just list them out okay you might notice
by the way like
who says this is the number we don't
actually know what the first digits are
right so for instance suppose the first
um sorry this is what i want suppose the
first six digits are this maybe it's one
two three four
five six and then there are two blanks
okay so now in this case what are the
different numbers i could put in there
there are three choices seven eight or
nine right
now because again i've got three numbers
to choose from and i'm going to put them
into these spots it's going to be the
same arrangement it's just going to be
for different numbers so i can do
seven eight or eight seven
i can do seven nine or nine seven
and i can do eight nine or nine eight
it's exactly the same
right so no matter which set you start
with you're always going to have six
more options to end with okay yeah will
it work like
um if you get the amount of numbers that
you can put in
yes okay okay okay good good so there's
the next way that i'm going to explain
it
rather than these ways suppose we
approach it like this
okay
um
these examples right all it means is i
block off six numbers there are six
numbers you can't choose from anymore
okay and then you need to fill in
what are the last two numbers okay the
second last number
and the last number that's all you
really care about okay now we know that
whichever we're at the start okay there
are only
nine digits
you can choose from in total
right because zero's out right they said
zero's out
so therefore if six have already been
taken any six right suppose it's like
random these two and
these four okay so those are the ones
that get used for your first six digits
okay
now i'm left with one
two
three digits to choose from there's
always three digits to choose from can
you see it might be one two three you
can choose from or seven eight nine or
one four nine whichever okay so now
think about this
how many different numbers can i put in
here
well i have three to choose from right
so i can put three possible ones
now after i put one of those numbers in
there how many numbers are there left
for me to choose from to put in here
there are there are two because i can't
use all three anymore one of them got
used here so now there are two possible
ones
so you've got to have both so it's
really three times two different ways
which is six okay now you're not
expected to know like there's a full
topic in c in stage six um called
permutations and combinations to read
really big fancy words which is all
about this okay
what you were expected to do was to say
well just try a scenario and then you
can this is the reason why they had to
eliminate the zero
because there are too many options
otherwise okay
but there you go there's the six
different ways so six is always going to
be the maximum number
all right